what's cooler than a petabyte of data
using the data to prove your customer
business your own business and even the
world
hello I'm Felipe Hoffa a Google cloud
developer advocate and today I'm in
Toronto Canada too with my good friends
at Utah they are the world largest
provider of telematics tracking more
than a million vehicles on the seven
continents and we're going to beat China
South their senior data scientist who's
going to show us how they manage all of
this data and even how you can use it to
understand how the world moves around
your house so let's get started
join me
[Music]
well here with us our senior data
scientist do top avianna hi Phillip
very welcome to Toronto I'm so happy to
be here and so what does tableau so geo
top is a telematics company will provide
open platform fleet management solution
to business of all kinds and all sizes
so we're now having over 20,000
customers with us and those customers
using the geotech devices to connect
their vehicles to their business so they
can manage the monitor the productivity
either the efficiency the safety and the
compliance of the drivers and vehicles
so we're now having over 1 million
devices ain't running vehicles and from
those vehicles we're collecting over 2.1
billion data set per day so whatever
device look like this is jus Tapco
device you can see it's a small box
beautiful and there is a whole bunch of
magic happening inside the box
collecting the data it's actually very
easy install you can just plug in play
even I can plug it yeah we have a
harness already installed on the truck
and the only thing you need to do is
just plug the device in and after a few
seconds you will hear pink and now it
started to work oh no it's data to your
platform that's right
how does data get it to the platform
once the device filtering and
calibration of the data there will the
device itself will just ensure that we
are sending the data that carries the
most information with the least Network
cost so withing I believe was in several
seconds the device data will goes into
customers databases as well as our Big
Data environment for analysis you are a
data scientist what's your job by the
scientist one part of my job is playing
with those data I'm very happy to have
this large volume of data to work with
from my can create whole bunch of
analysis from different angles to help
the internal
users to diagnose any possible potential
risks or flaws or bugs and on the other
hand I also work as a building engineer
so as an engineer I need to ensure that
I design and develop a reliable system
you have to create the pipelines store
the data securely yes analysis is
possible for everyone yeah and his
business grow I need to make sure in my
application survive for that long time
and I also grow cannot dab to the future
change value scale this platform as it
grows more complex it collects more data
more people are interested in looking at
it long ago did you start I started
YouTube in 2014 2014 four years ago yeah
I mean 2014 you chose bigquery because
you were able to finally put all of this
actually grow with bigquery we tested
with several called providers and then
women was Google bigquery and we were
very happy with the performance of the
bigquery API and also the capability of
pick return very big queries based of
large scale of data we were quite happy
with that and was there was big hurry so
how does it look like now so we're
having 2.1 billion data points per day
yeah when I joined in 2014 there were
around 300 million data per day so it's
almost six times of grow you would have
encouraged other team also to push their
data to to monitor do your work in in
bigquery so right now a few goes into to
have office you'll be surrounded by the
dashboards and monitors and where the
whole company is using data to monitor
the work and our work were data-driven
companies actually can you show me one
of these that's work yes okay as I
mentioned we're just these dashboards to
see how much data come in and how
quickly they're coming
to bakery wait a second this dashboard
is a Google slide yes and it's a life
dashboard it will be refreshed every
five minutes
well yeah and what can you see here so
from the top you can see the total
number of records were in pink right now
is over like one petabyte and more than
a petabyte right and just for today we
got over two point 1 billion rows
already well compare it to other reports
a year ago it's almost double and from
these gauges you can see like per second
we are having over 16 thousands of GPS
records and GPS records is less than one
third of our total data points so this
advice is not only recording the GPS
position so GPS position just one third
of it we also get all kinds of the
engine diagnostic data from the vehicle
engine computer such as whether the
driver is but buckle is the seat belt
how and also the fuel consumption
whether there is any like diagnostic
signal come out from the computer all
kind of things and also the temperature
also temperature so you're tracking part
of the inside of the track plane to your
connection yes yes and then this data
comes out from the device if your
platform it to be query right and you're
tracking the time that it takes to do
all of this yes so it's only seven
seconds seven seconds from device to
bigquery right and you have the chart of
the latency monitoring performance from
our servers so tell me more about this
like that's really in the background
we're running queries at the data in
bigquery we use the Jupiter notebook
which is hosted by Google Data lab we
used it we write queries in the log book
and produce all these pictures and
gauges
we push up these guys on to Google Cloud
storage and this Google slide can pull
those files from Google Cloud storage
and produce this beautiful dashboard and
jobs are setting and the Google slides
can actually refresh itself every five
minutes that's a really creative unity
of life and then to orchestrate these
queries oh yes because queries do have
dependencies and we are using the Apache
airflow to orchestrate those dependences
and it's easy for us to know is there
anything going on with either of the
dependencies so the query flies airflow
what else also we're doing Marshall
learning projects yep so we're using a
tensor flow as a framework we deploy
applications and pipe lies on to a
Google data flow and also are the Kuban
any clusters can you show me one of your
current projects yes it will be very
exciting to show you one of our website
we just launched it's called data dodge
your table comm do tab see the value in
big data and we want to show that those
value of big data can definitely empower
business because we're not just about
telematics and telematics is not just
about GPS in a position we have the
engine diagnostic from the vehicles
engine computer we have all kinds of
other data that comes from the auxilary
so jus cab can actually provide an open
platform so business can use those data
and even marry with other data sources
they have to create creative tools or
reports or any intelligence out of those
data so as a start point we produce a
set of intelligence data set to help
people to show people these are the
technical things that we can do with the
data
aggregating data within multiple
customers yes within multiple customers
because we want to make sure there's no
any privacy issues to confidentiality
issues and the customer need or the
users need to worry about their data and
we can see what's happening within
cities that's right either the
government or the people can divert this
data to do some solutions for the smart
city even so for example we analysis
what are they like
areas with high risk of in incidents so
you're empowering smart city governments
and drivers to see where are the
dangerous areas can I see the website
yes of course
theta dot your top cop within the
website you can find the Data Solutions
which is the ones that I mentioned that
we create some intelligence data at as a
starting point we have three categories
of those reports one is weather so you
believe it or not like the vehicles are
actually collecting the temperature and
the barometer pressure we can use this
data to report real-time and hyper local
temperatures you're getting hyper local
weather from all of these tracks
granularity with the regular weather
station might not be able to we also
have the urban thrust structure like the
high risk driving areas are one of them
if the third category is the local
location analytics so for example where
are the most popular gas stations and
what are the gas station types maybe
some of the gas stations are exclusively
for truck others are for passenger car
so we have those data and can help users
to locate their proper gas station and
also about the parking parking lots we
you can interestingly say like what are
the circle for parking so show me a
little more about the everybody
infrastructure what kind of data you're
called yeah there is
you want dataset at I produce which is
the hazardous driving area as I
mentioned we're collecting accelerometer
data so our former engineers calibrate
and clean those data and we also have a
whole bunch of talented engineer to do
lots a lots of experiments within the
real car the purpose for that is like we
need to find a threshold of the
acceleration so that we can detect okay
right now the driver is doing a
heartbreak or harsh heading or a hush
cornering and now you're counting the
number if you then yes and also as we
know that the bigger the study is the
more the incidents would potentially be
so we counted traffic flow within that
area and use that to normalize the
incident count and then we come up with
a score measure what's the level of risk
can we take take a look at the data yes
yes and so as a user you can actually
give your email address to register into
this website and then within maybe
several minutes you would get a response
email and just follow the instructions
you can get into our system to get the
data so anyone that registers and agrees
to the license of this data can take a
look at it and find what are the most
dangerous areas that's right
how would a quarter you look in a white
paper and website it has introduction to
what does this data said do and how
people can use this data set to produce
a whole bunch of insights we listed
several examples here as the first
example we're looking at the city's
prone to hazardous driving in Ontario
Canada but I live in California what if
I wanted to see what are the most
hazardous areas in California that would
be interesting so right now suppose I'm
already in the Vickery did I said you
already have permission to look at this
table what a little share within seven
seconds we get the results
and you can see a little bit the top
cities is Los Angeles because it's one
of the biggest cities - yes
followed by Long Beach San Francisco San
Diego Oakland and if we wanted to find
the points that were the most dangerous
point okay if you want to look at Los
Angeles this square is going over much
later the status ed itself is not very
big it's megabytes let's go so the fact
of this data is not impressive these
tables are about ten megabytes but
what's impressive eh how much you
produce them right in order to produce
this small table were actually run
analysis best of at least one year of
GPS and one year of acceleration and
maybe other data centers we need so in a
background there will be like over 50
terabytes of data or supporting this so
you're able to do everything with in
bigquery you can analyze those 50
terabytes publish the new tables and
make this tables available for anyone
that wants to access it that's right
so here the columns we have the average
latitude in average longitude this is
the location of it's at the average
location of the incidents happening
within a scope of the area and the size
of area is around 150 meter by a hundred
and 50 meter have the 50 meter square
yes and it will also give the boundary
points of this square we give four
points the whole point
and also the city-county if it's in the
state and the state of Poorman province
name country name is or country code
this every nice goal that I mentioned we
come up with those measurement and the
incident total total number of incidents
in fact so you have one count the first
row
this case has the area with the maximum
severity score yes that's right
and we also break down the incidence by
vehicle types which is like passenger
car hot truck on the road truck or on
the road vehicle off the road we'll call
a track tractors construction vehicles
or electrical vehicles and even like
natural gas vehicles but in other
columns we are capturing all kinds of
New Yorkers data so you are able to see
how traffic conditions vary depending on
the type of yes and people may be also
interested in ok what type of vehicles
are collecting them are creating the
most incidents on certain areas so they
can help their analysis based off more
granular data and then of the first row
you have the most hazardous one and the
second row we have one with that have
had more incident yeah if we wanted to
look at that yeah let's copy copy the
incident position and open Google map
with a street view we can jump into the
exact place it looks like this turn
around distribution center or
construction area which
like the driveway to the traffic without
any traffic light control okay show me a
little more about that like what's
happening behind the scenes to produce
these tables as I mentioned we use
notebook to explore to write queries in
this bore the results and actually
running the query jobs so first we need
to like calculate the traffic flow to
normalize the data we need to count the
incident from the raw accelerometer data
comes from the device and also a very
important step is we remove for the
differential information from this data
and then we aggregate and we set up the
jobs running in a background month by
month and day by day to collecting data
and run those reports that's how you end
up with a query like this one yeah we're
able to actually leverage the power from
bigquery we can write like the user
defined functions UDF's to set a custom
my state date that we want to look at
because these queries running as job we
cannot manually set a date so we use UDF
to define to get what's today's date and
with these sub queries so you can make
this queries look beautiful and easy to
manage then for each new hash for each
hour you're getting there yes we were
able to use such as array aggregation
function so the we can easily like
combination and manipulate many point
data is how much data with this query go
through this query so for one day of GPS
we'll probably have over 15 terabytes 50
yes and these queries can just finish
within minutes minute yeah it's really
amazing yeah if I was everything you're
doing it's really good and that's how
you are able to handle complexity you
this within L flowed yes that's right
there are lots of such queries running
in a background and we manage it in in a
diagram dependency diagram in the
airflow so we can monitor them and what
are the plans for the future so
definitely more intelligence data said
I'm gonna come out more intelligent data
nice and also as you said these jobs are
batch jobs around the analyst based on
historical data and in the future right
now I'm working on the streaming
analytics so we're hoping in the near
future we can really see the city map in
the real-time fashion say for example
you're gonna say what's the traffic flow
now on the roads across the road so you
will be able to produce streaming
analytics with better flow was data flow
yes
Apogee being in Cooper Nettie and also
yeah and also my coworkers are working
on a machine learning project to learn
the driving patterns of the fleet in
what we know it we can help the users to
compare the fleets we can kind of
benchmark the work to improve the
productivity in efficiency also the
safety and compliance yes so with
Matilda you will be able to extract more
knowledge produce actionable advice
improve the safety improve the
productivity yes we expand our insights
like we always did it we did it well but
with machine learning and the big data
we're going to have the capability to do
it with more deeper insights you know
I'm really impressed how you went from
like this device to disparate databases
to join all of this a different place
having how the platform has grown the
last four years it's impressive
yes I'm so glad you were able to you
wanted to share this data and analysis
with me yeah right because your hub is
believing in management by measurement
and we want to help other business to do
the same thing and it's we're driving
where
make decisions are driven by data and
we're gonna help people to do it -
that's really awesome so thank you for
joining us everyone well you can follow
me at Felipe Hoffa and keep tuned for
more that videos stay cool
[Music]
you